s'il vous là vous faites un plan incliné
évidemment là elle va tomber mais si
vous l'orienter doucement dans le sens
de la pente elle va tenir à condition
bien sûr que la pente ne soit pas trop
fort et voilà le secret de la tour de
pise l'un des milieux européens de
l'exposition archi capela pour matériaux
les célèbres capela en trente ans près
de 80 millions de planchette ont été
vendus j'ai déjà fait un point on
pouvait marcher dessus
moi j'ai déjà fait une grande tour j'ai
fait une tour qui monte jusqu'au plafond
et les caps là ils adorent donc c'est
très chouette de pouvoir leur montrer
des très belles réalisations ça leur
permet de donner des idées pour pouvoir
faire des choses à la maison version
miniature pas de colle mais environ
60000 planche est utilisé à la
réalisation des enfants versailles et du
ce2 au cm2 il faut une dextérité
manuelle tout de même fine fine parce
que les équilibres sont complexes même
les maisons vous regarderez au centre du
delà de la chapelle il y a d'la d'une
petite maison mais même pour faire les
fenêtres c'est déjà on se met sur une
demi épaisseur de kapla voyez parfois la
planche donc c'est déjà delà de la
manipulation fils
l'exposition est un vrai succès depuis
son ouverture le 23 décembre dernier la
file d'attenté en témoigne 1200
visiteurs en moyenne voyagent chaque
jour